We need to modify the service worker
to intercept requests to the API.
And store responses in the cache so
that we can easily access them later.
It's good practice to
keep the resources for
your app shell separate
from the application data.
That way you can update one
without disturbing the other.
In the service-worker,
I've added a data cache name
variable to the service-worker.
Next, I need to modify
the fetch event handler
to handle requests to the data
API separate from other requests.
The fetch event handler first
checks the requested URL
to see if it starts with
the address of the weather API.
If it does,
it makes a network request for the data.
Once the response is returned
the code opens the data cache,
clones the response,
stores it in the cache.
And finally returns the response
to the original requester.